Okay. So let us implement our recurrent
neural network and we are going to do it
uh in this setup to analyze this data
set of IMDb
movie reviews. So it's a data set for
sentiment classification. We are going
to download this from Kaggle. And here I
have the download download download page
here. As you can see each review has a
label positive and negative. So these
reviews are collected to be a bit
extreme uh to basically make it easier
for our natural language processor to
classify. So we are going to use this
data set and uh we built first a vanilla
recurrent neural network that takes in
each review and predicts the label
either positive or negative review. the
problem fall into this class. We take in
the sequence and at the end given the
final hidden state we will classify the
review as positive or negative. Things
to consider is we are batching variable
length sentences. So we have to pad them
to all have the same size for the GPU.
And also of course we need to translate
the the natural language to numerical
values because that's how computer
understand. So to do that we are mapping
each token to a to an ID and since we
want the vocabulary size to be finite we
choose a max vocabulary size which is
less than the number of tokens and that
means that there are some rare tokens
that doesn't get any um ID and we are
going to just assign unknown to them and
they that will not affect the analysis a
lot because they are not happen they are
not occurring a lot. So we discussed the
the basics of the recurrent neural
network cell that uh takes in the input
and out and the previous hidden um with
the tangent hyperbolic activation. We
will discuss this while we are coding
the cell. So another note on why we need
padding. We want to make this special
token for the padded values and make
sure that our recurren neural network
knows that this is a padded value and
while uh going forward if for example
this last one is just a padded value we
want to make sure the hidden state will
be unaffected by this. So making sure
that the RN knows this is a padded value
and not updating the the hidden state.
Um there are some utility functions here
that I included for you and here
basically how to download the data set
and there is a possibility for having a
toy uh data set that in case uh you want
to do prototyping but I suggest working
on the real data set if you have GPU
from the get- go. So uh it's possible to
use torch text for downloading the data
set but sometimes uh because torch text
is not maintained anymore uh at least
updated uh so you can just manually
download it and I provided the text here
and the code. So like I said we have to
uh handle the p padded values and making
sure that they get the special tokens
while we are handling them during the
RNN architecture. So like I said, I'm
going to skip this details and you can
look at them. There are some helper
functions later when we do the training
for plotting the histories and and
finalizing the presentation of the
results like for example using a
confusion matrix because this is a
binary classification. Here I took the
opportunity to introduce this decorators
that can uh simplify our code. Uh, one
of them is this data class that you will
see how it can save some of our time and
make our code cleaner. So, I added an
explanation here and how uh what's what
does this decorator do? Um, I'm planning
to compile some of these most useful
decorators in PyTorch and include that
in the in the lecture as a Google collab
notebook. Okay. So we are all set to
start writing the our uh recurrent
neural network. So as we discussed
basically a recurrent neural network
cell takes in the token of course the ID
of the token we already did the
embedding and then we have to write like
a linear mapping here to map the the
token ID to uh the hidden space. uh that
um linear mapping is a is basically a a
weight matrix and uh we discussed that
we have to take in the previous age
again with a weight matrix in the
lecture I I said that uh we can combine
them for the analysis and actually it
helps if we do it in the GPU because we
don't need to handle two different
weight matrix. So here I'm calling this
one we wh and this one w ih like I said
in the lecture I said we can combine
them and we have one larger w and these
two inputs can be concatenated and
inputed to that due to the issues that
we have in vanilla RNN and the fact that
when we compute this back propagation
through time we said that this weight wh
uh takes an important role because of uh
exponentiation that they have. So to
make our uh simple RNN works going to
separate them to have WI uh here and WHh
and mainly because of the importance of
the weight initialization here. Um later
when we go to LSDM we combine them. So
you will see that uh that's not a big
deal there. So for now going to separate
WH and WHh and like I said mainly
because of the initialization of the
weight and I want to make sure this WH
products will remain stable and uh
initialization helps here. Okay. So with
that caveat we start the code. We are
writing a vanilla RN cell for now and
then we need to have a linear layer for
WH and WHh.
Okay. So um just to familiarize you with
the lingo here. So this linear layers we
call them sometimes dense layer and
sometimes an aphine uh layer. Basically
it's a fine because it's a linear plus a
bias right. Um so when I say this is an
input hidden a fine it means that it's a
linear layer. Okay. So one thing else
actually this it's good to say here uh I
don't want the wh to have a to have bias
um this is a classic uh RNN
parameterization you will see that um
this will be helpful when we are dealing
with the initialization tool like I said
again it's about stability of this
exponentiation of whh doing the the back
propagation so let's state that that the
bias is false and then introduce uh
initialization here we are going to have
a tangent hyperbolic so let's use
heavier uh uniform for the w then for
the whh which I like I said it's more uh
sensitive so we want to use orthogonal
but basically we want to preserve the
norm across this time steps so uh if you
remember uh as explained in the book
also the largest value or the spectrum
radius of this matrix takes an important
role in this exponentiation. So we want
to make sure it is scaled. So even
taking an extra step to make sure this
scaling is happening is advice here. I'm
not going to do it here but scaling with
spectral radius is also handy. Um and
LSM is not as sensitive as uh this
vanilla RNN. So most of these steps will
be unnecessary really. We have to
initialize the the bias term for the WH.
So let's do it. Okay. And I think we're
good. We can move on to the forward. And
remember that we are just writing the
cell here. So a torch tangent hyperbolic
of the two. And that's it. So this is
our vanilla RN cell. And then we unroll
the the sequence of this uh cells. So
let's write this. for the unrolling of
the cells we write this class. So
basically what it does is to takes the x
uh of course a batch of them along with
the length of them like uh we discussed
in the processing of the data. So we
need to know the length of them and the
main reason is we want to mask those um
padded values and we don't want our RNN
to process them right so that's why we
need the length of each sequence and uh
we get a batch of these padded sequences
and at the end we want to return the
last hidden state to the classification
head that we will write in a different
class. Okay. So with that this is the
the cell and um I mean uh we can have
different type of cell right. So here
here we have the vanilla RNN cell but we
can also have the LSTM cell. The cell is
defined. We already have a forward
method within the cell. So we can use
that and then the rest is basically to
make sure we process this hidden state
and update them along the sequence and
making sure we are not doing it over the
the padded values. Okay. So that happens
all in the forward method. So the input
will be let's say x and uh what is x is
basically x is a a tensor of this shape.
Let me just so x uh shape will be badge
length of the time and the embedding the
embedded tokens. Okay. So that's our
shape. Yeah. So uh if we want this to
work with uh different type of cell that
may have different hidden size, right?
In that case we need to take that uh
properties from the cell itself. So in
that case we have um basically features
of the the cell and uh and using we will
use that to to get the uh the hidden
size. So for now to simplify the process
we are going to do this uh by hand but
uh
I will make sure in the full code that I
will share with you uh I will I will
include that feature. So because now the
hidden size is like I said determined.
So let's just make sure we have it here
too. Okay. So now uh the forward takes
in x the length and we can think of so
because we we only need the last age. Um
we don't need to return the the rest of
them. So let's just take in x and
length. Oh because I want the most
simple code here. Let's just write this.
So if we write it this way, it basically
makes sure that the device is also the
same as x. So that's why it's handier.
So for uh t in the range of t, we get
the updated age from the cell. So let's
call it h candidate that is given by the
cell and the cell starts from x and h.
So x and h and the first h we define it
here. So starting with the first h here
which is zeros. Okay. So that's the h
candidate. We want to make sure that the
mask is uh constructed. So going to call
mask t we get the h we want h to be to
handle mask. Okay. So basically what we
are doing is we keep the this h
candidate whenever it's not masked right
so this is just like a 01 kind of mask
vector. If it's mask it will be zero and
it will keep the previous h. So when
it's padded doesn't update and it keeps
the previous age. Um I'm thinking even
we don't need this. So we're just
returning h right. So this is how we
handle this padding and we make sure h
is not corrupted by the by the padded
value and we return h at the end. So now
we can write the end to end uh class
that um use the cell and um the sequence
at the classification head at at the end
and also embedding at the beginning.
Okay. So with that let's write let's
call it from scratch arn. So here uh we
need to know the vocabulary size um the
embedding dimension and the hidden size.
uh the vocabulary size or the number of
uh tokens that we ided and then here
this is an important component basically
determines the dimension of the
embedding of this u each one of these
tokens so we embed each one of these
tokens so think of it like a a linear um
layer so I write it this way the self
embedding uh it's not within super so
self dot embedding is a is a linear
layer that takes in this um token ids
and maps it to a e dimensional vector.
Okay, one thing that is important here
is we really don't want to learn
anything for the padding uh tokens. So
we want to ensure that even the
embedding layer doesn't do anything for
those pad values. So remember that first
we made sure that the pads are not
corrupting our edge and here I we want
to also make sure it's not corrupting
our embedding right so we want to force
this uh embedding of the pads to be for
example zero uh vector in this embedding
space. So to do that uh we have to do
some more treatment. So we want to start
from some initial let's say embedding
vectors. Uh initial it can be some
noise. Uh for example let's initialize
this embedding weight right let's just
do with normal and then uh with some
mean zero and very small standard
deviation right. Um and then I want to
say if self
embedding is for the padding index which
we uh determined. So if self embedding
embedded padding index is not none. So
we have a padding index we want to make
sure that its weight is zero of this
self is just zero absolute zero. That's
that. uh we made sure we first mildly
randomized the embedding right and then
we forced the rows uh corresponding to
this pads to be exactly zero. I think we
have the components the embedding let's
just call the sequence and we have the
the fully connected head which is a
linear and now we can write the forward
method. Okay. Okay. So this gives us the
the logits right. So if you want to
visualize the embedding uh vectors um
you can uh maybe rename this to
something else and u directly return
this for visualization purposes. Okay.
So that's that we have the RNN. Let's
put everything together here. This is
our RNN code and that's basically it's
ready for training. Okay. So um because
uh it's expensive to train. Let me uh
write the LSDM cell before training and
seeing the result and then we can
compare the two. Okay. So let's carry on
uh with uh coding our um RNN from
scratch. We did the vanilla RNN. Now we
want to do the LSTM cell first and then
doing the sequence just very similar to
what we did with the RN. We learned that
in LSTM we have a separate um memory
that is the long memory and we keep this
short-term memory that we call H. So
here uh unlike in the RNN case we can
catenate this four uh linear layers into
one um I mean we instead of having one a
fine for each one of this activation. We
put one large linear layer here that uh
takes in XT and HD concatenated, right?
Remember that x is the embedding and we
apply one large linear transformation
and uh that basically maps the input to
a four times hidden size because we
split each one of them uh we basically
learn each one of them separately for
their respective gates or activation.
Okay. So this is basically this. So this
is a very nice uh blog post by Colola
that um you can look at and I used the
images here but uh just to recap we had
the first gate and then the second gate
that acts on this candidate lung memory
and then the third one so FT and LT. So
with that nomencle let's go back here we
have FT it and uh OT. So CT at the end
will be the FT here that gates the
previous C the IT here that gates the
candidate GT here. Okay. So this is GT
and that gives the new correction on the
long memory. Okay. So talking about this
and then at the end we have this gate
that takes in the the long memory the
updated long memory and gates it for the
new short memory. Okay. So that's what
we are going to do with that. Let's
write the class. Okay. LSTM cell and
then module and class TM cell and
module. Great. So let's self hidden and
rest. Let's Okay. Like I said, we need
uh one fused a fine for all of these
gates. Um uh same discussion as before.
It's much faster on GPU and uh the
initialization is not sensitive. Now and
we are going to use Javier here and uh
so that's why we fuse all of them
together. So let's write one w for all
that takes in the concatenated input and
return four times hidden size. So input
size plus hidden size. Oh I see that uh
the suggestion note the s suggestion
separates them. We are not going to do
it. Let's just simplify. So we have one
W for all is not false. Let's keep that.
So let's do the initialization. So with
not or no grad. Okay. So recall the gate
order is uh this. So okay. So um so when
we initialize the the biases to be zero
it means that initially the the
forgetting gate will be the um so here
initially because like I said the
initial is zero weights are zero so we
will get taking just the bias here and
the um sigma of this zero is 0.5 and um
so initially we have 0.5 we're
which over k steps it will be very fast
forgetting. So we are looking at 0.5 ra
to k. So the cell forgets very quickly
before learns anything. We really want
to slow down the forgetting at the
beginning. So be in the beginning I like
this forget the bias for the forgetting
to be rather large. So for example if
the the value of the the bias here is
one sigma of one will be uh 73 I think
and that means that the forgetting is um
is less or in other word the cell leaks
less so information isn't erased
immediately
uh we want to make sure that's happening
otherwise that doesn't really learn much
okay so for that I'm going to first get
the the view of this biases. So I'm
going to reshape that to um four and
eight. We have four of them. So now we
have we address the for each gate row
and we are going to make sure the first
forgetting is not zero. Okay. So that's
good. I think we are good to go with
that. We can write the forward. Okay, so
we're taking x at step t. Let's just
specify that we take h of previous,
right? And we take c of previous more
clear. So x what what's x is the
dimension is batch and embedding. H
dimension is batch and h c dimension is
b and h. Okay. So at the end what we
want from this cell we want to give us
the new hidden and the new cell state we
just call it cell. Let's also return the
the value of the gates for visualization
right we want to know for example for a
sequence how this gates are um opening
and closing. Okay. So now let's do the
the gate chunking. Um um so we have Z we
um we have H that is the the hidden
size. So this way we have the the value
of Z corresponding to this chunks and
then we can do the activation going to
trust this suggestion and with that
let's okay so with that fix some
indentation error that I had and I have
this gate setup we are making the
gradient highway here with our additive
path that keeps the previous C with the
gate and then write this new G. Okay, so
let's expose the shortterm memory with
the output gate. Um that's that actually
let's just want to make sure we are
explicit enough. Okay, so now that's
that and like I said we we want to do
some plotting of this gate values. Let's
do that.
Okay, so that's our cell. Now we can
write the the sequence of this that
unrolls the cells for the for the batch
sequences. Right? So LSTM sequence
let's uh just make it similar to what we
wrote before. Okay. So we will do the
same here. So that's our cell. We want a
bunch of them. So let's write the for.
Don't know why the indentation is just
not doing it. Okay. Let's just make this
simpler. Okay. To call this H. Okay. So,
and then um let's write a empty list for
this H and C's. And then 14 range. We
have this mask of T.
Good. And then we have XT. Let's just
Okay. So now we can apply the mask to
both hidden and um and the cell states.
Okay. So age will be mask
and see that create and then we
append all of them and then let's just
return H separately. It will be easier
and last time we didn't really return
all of the H and C's, right? So let's we
can avoid returning them right with that
let's write uh the class from scratch
lstm very similar right um self
embedding it's the same the sequence now
it's taking the LSTM sequence and FC is
that we do the uh the embedding u uh in
it just like before right and then write
the F uh 4. Okay, so we have everything
uh ready for training. So going to write
a train config that is basically shows
the training configuration for both RNN
and LSTM. So I'm going to write a data
class for that and the train config. So
let's just write something we can update
later. So the good the good thing good
thing about this data class is we can
later update it. um let's say three
learning rate the float um 2 e minus I
don't know three for example uh batch
size can be how many sequences we load
each time and let's say 128 um let's
also define a clipping value for our
gradient right let's say five I mean
this is essential for RN even for LSTM
it helps stabilizing the gates we can
write the training. Uh so I'm going to
skip this and just show you the code.
Okay, so this is the training we are
using Adam. Um Adam is very good for
LSTM. Uh the cross entropy here is
basically a soft max uh cross entropy
for the two classes takes in the loits.
Here we are tracking the total gradient
and then we do the clipping and after
that we do the the gradient step. Here
we have the evaluation of course no grad
and then we log uh we still need some
utility functions for our confusion
matrix and uh after that um I'd like to
have a a function that basically looks
at the gates of the LSTM and we want
that to for visualization. So I'm going
to write that offline. Okay. So here is
what we have. Uh um so let's go with
this embedding dimension and the hidden
state uh size the learning rate we
already defined um this is how we are
loading the data and then we build the
vocabulary data loaders and some
printing uh so let's run them first so
while it's running let's go to the
training of the models uh we have the
the RNN and LSTM both from scratch
I'm out of CUDA here, so it may take
some time. Uh the training script is
very similar to what you already know.
Uh and at the end, I want to take a look
at this LSTM gates for a very obvious
case of like what is this preview? Okay.
Okay. We have an error embedded.
Let's find this.
Um okay. embedding.
Okay, another typo. Let's go back. Oh, I
see this is a self. Okay. Okay. So, here
we didn't define this. Let's just define
it. What else?
Oh, yep. Of course, this is Yep. Let's
fix this.
Next error. Okay. Some indentation
probably here. Okay. Okay. So after
fixing a few indentation errors, it is
running now. So if there is a error, I
will let you know otherwise um this will
take some time because of the I'm out of
GPU. So it will take some time. Okay. So
here is the result. Um we see that the
loss is going down in training and um
you see the accuracy which is pretty
high uh compared to the simplicity of
the architectures and the number of
samples we are getting a good accuracy.
Uh you see the gradient norm for the
LSCM is keeping very low and for the RNN
it goes beyond five the value that we do
clipping. So there will be a lot of
clipping in the RNN. Here is the uh
confusion matrix. You see that in the
RNN case we have a I would say good
accuracy for uh both negative and
positive. We have better performance for
the LSDM. We see that uh we capture the
positives reviews better. Uh so there
will be less false positive and false
negative in the LSTM case. And here are
the gates for this specific example.
Amazing, wonderful, perfect movie. Of
course, everything is positive here. So
the gate uh the forgetting gate is not
really um doing a lot of forgetting.
Apparently it's uh keeping the memory uh
the long-term memory over the sequence.
Okay. So with that uh uh we will look at
more complex RNN tasks not just many to
one. If you remember we said in the case
of classification here we are giving the
sequence or the review and classify it.
In the case of translation for example
translation from English to French which
will be in the homework. uh we have this
sequence and uh we are translating it to
another sequence. So in the decoding
part we have another RNN or LSTM. This
will be in the homework and this
architecture is known as sequence to
sequence and it has been the driving
force behind Google translate for many
years and you will see uh and implement
this in your homework. Heart.